the governor of Oregon has commuted all
death sentences for the 17 individuals
on death row in Oregon the governor is
against the death penalty and I think
that this is an absolutely fantastic
decision CNN reports Oregon governor
calls death penalty immoral commute
sentences for all 17 inmates on debt on
death row outgoing Oregon governor Kate
Brown is commuting the sentences of all
17 people on death row to life
imprisonment without the possibility of
parole according to a news release
yesterday she said since taking office
in 2015 I have continued Oregon's
moratorium on executions because the
death penalty is both dysfunctional and
immoral today I am commuting Oregon's
death row so that we will no longer have
anyone serving a sentence of death and
facing execution in this state she used
executive clemency powers to commute the
sentences it is set to take effect today
now important to understand about the
death penalty in Oregon generally as the
article says Oregon has executed two
people since the U.S Supreme Court
reinstated the death penalty in 1976 and
since Oregon reinstated the death
penalty in 1984 the most recent was in
1997. I think that this is a fantastic
decision
I'm against the death penalty I believe
we should all be against the death
penalty and there are so many reasons
some of which I will tell you right now
now I want to say up front so sometimes
there are people who are against the
death penalty for three of the reasons
I'm going to mention and they will say
David that fourth reason isn't very good
it's sort of fallacious actually
let's take them one at a time and I know
specifically what people are talking
about but let's take them one at a time
first of all
if we believe that human lives have
inherent value which is often part of
the justification for the death penalty
meaning it goes something like human
life has inherent value and so when you
take a life you are giving up your right
to live and therefore the state can or
should take your life intentionally if
we are against the intentional taking of
lives which have inherent value
then we can't say except when the person
has done a b or c at which point the
state should get involved in the
business of taking life nope doesn't
make sense the state should not be
involved in that and I am against it
secondly
there are wrongful convictions all the
time in our justice system and in
addition to there being innocent people
on death row there are also many
cognitively limited people on death row
and so because we can't possibly get it
right we can't accept as a society the
possibility of putting to death someone
who may be innocent now you could say
but David what if the system were
perfect and there were no one innocent I
would still be against it for the other
reasons that I'm mentioning so don't
just because one reason alone isn't
bulletproof don't say it's not a reason
the state shouldn't be taking lives and
there are innocent people on death row
and there are cognitively limited people
on death rope solving just one of those
things doesn't actually change anything
you can't undo
taking a life whereas if you imprison
someone and they're innocent there's at
least the chance of fixing it and
compensating them in the future
third it does not appear as though the
death penalty is an effective deterrent
to crime and that it is not actually
making Society safer it's it's beyond
the scope of this segment to look at
that uh but it's been widely studied and
so if it's not a deterrent then why are
we putting the state in the position of
obtaining the chemicals that we use
which sometimes work and sometimes take
hours it doesn't make any sense I also
don't think that the death penalty is
the harshest sentence for the offender
and what I mean by that is based on my
beliefs you put someone to death and the
lights go out and they're suffering or
living with the consequences of their
actions ends if you put someone in
prison without the possibility of parole
they're gonna sit there for however long
they live
living with the reality of what they did
and that they now live in a box forever
now I am not one to say that there
should be extra punishments like for
example prison rape I'm against that
those are indications that our prison
system is unable to keep inmates safe
but I do believe that turning the lights
off for lack of a better term is a less
harsh punishment than making someone sit
in prison for the rest of their life so
if your desire is the worst possible
punishment and experience for the
offender it's life in prison without
parole and then if your concerns are
Financial if you care about money it's
cheaper to do prison without the
possibility of parole because in our
system uh individuals on death row have
significant access to appeals now some
people will say get rid of the appeals
no no we need those appeals because
there are so many innocent people on
death row so there is no reason to
before the death penalty and I think
what Kate Brown is doing is absolutely
fantastic and I'm glad to see that she
did it